MAXIM MAI: Thank you so
much for being here today.
And most of all, thank you so
much for giving up your spot
in the sun outside to come
back, sit down, and come
on this journey with us to
learn about sustainable growth.
I'll be joined shortly onstage
by my formidable colleague
Marie Loridan and later by
the amazing Andy Carvell,
formerly of SoundCloud.
But first, let's
talk a little bit
about what this
session is about.
So what do I mean by
saying sustainable growth
solves most problems?
And I'll tell you a
little bit about my goals.
So my first goal for today
is to introduce all of you
to a very simple yet
powerful framework
that you can use to
systematically accelerate
the growth trajectory
of your app.
And the second goal for today is
to share with you some insights
of partners or developers--
some of them are in the audience
today-- that are using growth
tools, techniques, and tactics
to accelerate their app.
And hopefully you'll
walk away inspired
and try some of these
methods yourself.
But first of all, let's all
accept the growth challenge.
So what do I mean by that?
I want you to come
on a journey with me
to kind of understand
the importance of having
a structured approach
to growth for your app.
Let's have a show of hands here.
Who in the audience here
considers her or himself
a growth-hacking expert?
We should have at least one.
Because we have Andy
in the audience.
Oh, OK, I see you're
all shy, maybe still
very full from lunch, and
hopefully not half asleep yet.
OK, so we don't have any
growth hacking experts.
That's excellent.
You came to the right talk.
So expert or not,
I hope that you all
agree with me when
I say that one
of the important factors
in why growth, or achieving
sustainable growth in the
long run, is so difficult
is that the individual
tactics and tools
and techniques that
people are using
are not only complex
in themselves,
but importantly, they're
also very interconnected.
And so it's tempting to obsess
about one or two or three
individual tactics and
master them, but kind of
lose sight of the big picture.
And so for example, let's
look at performance marketing.
So there was a recent study
that showed that marketers
are using dozens of
channels and ad formats
to reach their users.
So this is just looking
at paid marketing.
And for me, that already looks
like a very, very complicated
subject to master-- just
performance marketing.
But of course, we haven't
even thought about
or haven't even looked at
all of the organic ways
of driving users to your app,
and the interdependencies
between those.
Also for us at least, or
when I think about growth,
growth involves much, much
more than user acquisition.
So in fact, I'm
certain that almost all
of you here in
the audience today
are working on strategies to
better engage and retain users.
In fact, at the recent Play
event earlier in the year,
we did roundtable discussions.
And there, developers--
almost every single person
I talked to-- told me that they
obsess about the onboarding
experience in their app to make
sure that new users sign up
or activate push
notifications to then later
be able to target them better
with life cycle marketing
campaigns.
Now, those are just
two things-- so
onboarding experience, or
first-time user experience,
and lifecycle marketing.
But there are a
lot of other things
that people are
doing to drive growth
and engagement and retention
and, ultimately, usage
of their app.
And of course,
eventually, all of us
will care about revenue
and/or growing revenue.
But of course, how much
you focus on revenue
depends on the lifecycle stage
of the venture that you're
working on or the
maturity of your product.
So one way that people
are optimizing or growing
their revenue is by optimizing
their pricing strategy.
But it's much more than
just deciding on a price.
So developers-- top
developers like Netflix--
they're using a lot of
very subtle strategies.
And they're experimenting
with things like price tiering
and price anchoring to
influence purchase decisions.
And a lot of you are
doing that as well.
So pricing is only
one of the many things
that people are thinking
about when they're
thinking about growing revenue.
You have to think about,
how do you capture value
in the first place
from partners?
How do you have your
office strategy?
How do you process payments?
So I work with a lot of you,
and a lot of top partners
personally, on a lot of
these topics and issues.
And I think it gets fairly
complex fairly quickly.
And luckily, there are a lot
of people in the growth hacking
community, growth
professionals, that
are looking for ways to
put some sort of structure
on growth, on this wild
field, on this complex topic,
and trying to understand
all of the interdependencies
and enable them to
prioritize better
and to ultimately accelerate
their growth strategy.
So one of these people will
be on stage later-- Andy.
And a couple of people around
him in the growth hacking
community have been thinking
a lot about one of these tools
to structure growth.
And I want to give you a very
brief introduction to a growth
hacking framework.
So the first thing
that you should do
is actually to take a step back.
And so just before looking
at any of the tools, tactics,
and techniques, think about your
high-level business objectives,
whatever they are.
So if you're early
in your venture,
maybe you're just
trying to validate
a minimum viable product.
Or you're trying to
double sales on mobile.
Or you're maybe
looking for investment,
and you want to raise
a round of investments.
Now think about how
those high-level business
objectives-- what do they
mean for your growth strategy,
for how you define
growth for yourself?
And you will start to
notice that you'll probably,
without looking at
anything individual,
be interested to
focus more strongly
on one of these three things.
Maybe you'll focus on all.
But it will sort of give
you an initial idea on where
you might want to focus.
Also, of course,
important are not
just your business objectives
but also your resources
and your constraints.
And I'll talk about that
a little bit later on.
So let's talk about
how to apply that.
So tactics-- all the
things I mentioned earlier
are your kind of tools,
tactics, strategies that
are available for you to use.
And this, by the way, is
not an exhaustive list.
There are many, many other
things that people are doing.
But when you're
evaluating an activity,
think about, how does
this particular activity
fit into my overall strategy?
So you can do that for the
activities that foster user
acquisition or accelerate
user acquisition.
You can do that for
activities that increase
engagement and retention.
And you can do that
for growing revenue.
And I'm not saying you should
be doing all of these things.
You should be looking at
every single tactic in light
of your overall objectives,
your resources, and maybe
your constraints.
But then once you have sort
of assembled your toolset
for growth, there's
another important thing
that you need to do.
And that is build the right
business intelligence tools
and infrastructure to be
able to track your progress.
And I can't emphasize
how important this is.
Because when you
invest in these areas,
you're using resources that
you might use for other things
instead.
So you need to be able to
track the impact that you're
having, that your teams are
having, on these individual
areas.
So you might want
to assign one or two
actionable and measurable KPIs
to each of those investments.
So maybe when you're thinking
about optimizing your Play
listing, think about the visit
to in-store conversion rate
and how all the things
that you're doing
are impacting that
in the long run.
Or when you're thinking
of your onboarding flow,
define a metric that captures
your activation rate-- how
good you are at activating
users, how good you are
at introducing the
product to your users
when they install the app.
Or when you're thinking
about growing revenue,
you might think, OK, here
are my payment processors.
What's the percentage
of failed payments?
And how can I
increase the coverage
when I enter new markets?
So that's very
important-- the KPIs
and being able to measure them.
Now let's think
of one-- I'd like
to explain a very simple
application of this framework.
It's not an exercise
in pretty drawings.
But think of the concept
of a growth card, right?
So you've selected the
activities you want to do.
You've got your KPIs.
And you can measure them.
Now try to benchmark against
either internal goals
or industry averages.
So you might actually find--
let's go back to the Play Store
optimization example.
You might actually find
that your conversion rate
is actually very good
compared to country benchmarks
or industry benchmarks.
You might find that maybe
your activation rate is OK.
It's not super great.
But compared to the goals
you set for yourself,
it's quite good.
But then you might find that
payment is really an issue.
And I'm just using
these as examples.
But this is how having a
scorecard to guide your growth
strategy can be very, very,
very useful and helpful.
So that's enough theory for
one afternoon after lunch.
Now I would like to talk
a little bit about what
our top Android
developers are doing
with some of these
techniques to drive growth.
Now, I'll be focusing mostly
on the organic techniques.
That's what I do in my day job.
And then Marie will come
up and talk a little bit
about paid techniques.
So first up, I'd like to
talk a little bit about Clue.
So this is a period tracking
and female health app.
And they're based
here in Berlin.
So late last year, they
went through an exercise
quite similar to
the growth framework
that I introduced just before.
So we were trying to figure
out, where are the bottlenecks,
or which areas needed more
investment to accelerate
the growth curve on Android?
And one of the things
that we identified
was that the in-store
conversion rate was quite low,
or was lower than
it needed to be.
So the folks at
Clue really came up
with a long-term strategy of
running lots of little Play
listing experiments to
increase the conversion rate.
And over the course
of about six months,
they increased the
conversion rate by 24%.
And that's huge.
So that means that 24%
more users install the app
without spending anything
more on advertising or doing
any PR work or anything.
So that's just with the
users that are already
arriving on the Play listing.
So just to give
you one quick test,
so which of the two
images do you think
had a higher visit to download
conversion rate, the left one
or the right one?
So have a show of hands for
the left one, on your left.
OK, so that's the black one.
OK, and the others?
OK, yeah, so the
white one-- there's
actually two factors there
that got tested individually.
The white phone drove a
higher conversion rate
and larger image.
So that's a really,
really cool insight here.
The next thing I
want to talk about,
in terms of the toolsets
that you have available,
is an example from a non-profit,
which is ShareTheMeal,
also based here in Berlin.
And these guys, I'm sure, also
did a very sophisticated growth
analysis.
But one of the
restrictions that they have
is that they're a non-profit.
So they can't actually spend
any money on advertising.
So they sort of evaluated
their constraints
and then thought, well, one
of the things we can do,
and we can do very well,
is public relations.
And I think it's a tool
that's often overlooked,
because it's hard to do well.
But when you do it well, it
can be very, very powerful.
So it's also hard to track.
But they have to
track the impact.
So they estimate about
50% of all total installs
were driven by public relations.
And a couple of the
insights there are you
need to really focus on
excellent messaging and having
the right hooks, and also
to combine public relations
with other initiatives, such
as partnerships work, or maybe
press work partnerships, and
maybe viral hooks, something
like that.
I also want to talk a
little bit about virality.
So I'm sure you guys
all know Dubsmash.
I don't know if
anyone from Dubsmash
is here today-- I think so.
No-- or maybe you
don't want to say.
So Dubsmash is a social
video messaging platform.
And basically what it does is
it allows you to create videos
for yourself that are dubbed.
And you can lip sync to songs.
And this is really, really fun.
And in a way, virality is
built into the product, right?
It's not very fun looking
at yourself singing along
to songs.
So sharing and reaching
other users is built in.
And it has been
hugely successful.
And growth has been phenomenal.
But the point I want to make
is that even if virality
isn't built into your product--
so if your product isn't
the perfect fit for
viral mechanics--
there are a couple of
things that you can look out
for to make sure that you make
sharing as easy as possible.
So there are really two factors.
One has a very fun name.
It's called the K factor.
And it basically describes,
how many new users does
one user bring into the app?
So that's something
that you might
want to work on improving
by making it easier
to share with other users.
So that can have a really nice
impact on your organic growth.
Another factor that you
might want to look at
is the cycle time.
And that just means,
how short or how long is
the interval between me sharing
with friends and those friends
coming back to the
app or installing
the app for the first time
and then sharing again?
So shortening that time can also
be a very, very, very powerful
factor of increasing the
viral growth of your app.
So think about making sharing
easy, accessible, encouraging,
incentivizing sharing.
One final thing I want to talk
about in this quick session
is cross-promotion.
So cross-promotion, if you
already have a popular app,
can be a very,
very powerful tool.
So Freeletics did
this very well.
So for me, cross-promotion isn't
just injecting an interstitial
and showing it to all
your existing users
to promote a new product.
But doing it in a clever
way works very well.
So for example, Freeletics
injected nutrition information
to the activity stream for
all their bodyweight users.
And so that got
people who were just
interested in fitness
interested in nutrition as well.
And some of them clicked
through to the app.
And there are various
other subtle ways
of using cross-promotion
to promote a new product.
And this was very, very, very
successful for Freeletics.
So when they launched
the nutrition app,
almost all of the sales
were made to existing users
of existing apps.
So that's my part talking
about organic tactics.
I'd now like to ask Marie
onstage to talk a little bit
about performance marketing.
[APPLAUSE]
MARIE LORIDAN: Hi, everyone.
At Google I/O, we
announced that mobile app
install ads had driven
over 2 billion installs.
This number is now 3 billion.
This is truly growth hacking.
How did we achieve that?
At Google, we take our
promotion very seriously,
and have been heavily
investing in building us
the tools that will help you
drive installs and also make
sure that your users stay
active within the app.
You've heard earlier
in the opening
that we had launched universal
app campaigns last year
as a very simple
way to actually show
your ads on the full set of
our inventory, which includes
Google Search, the Google
Play Store, our Google Display
Network, and YouTube.
What you need to run
universal app campaigns
is only four lines of text.
Then we do the rest for you.
We generate creatives using
your Play Store assets.
And we use, for
example, your app icon.
Then we run the ads and
optimize them for you
automatically through our
machine learning solution
or conversion optimizer.
So this has been
extremely successful
and helped a lot of advertisers
to drive installs with success.
Now I'd like to do
a show of hands.
But because I feel the energy
is a bit down after lunch,
I'd like you to stand
up if you already
used paid marketing before.
Can you please
stand up if you've
used performance marketing?
So let's say about
half the room.
All right, now you-- oh,
everybody sit down, OK.
So hopefully you moved.
And now you're
energized again-- right.
So obviously, if you stood up
or if you didn't, universal app
campaigns is truly something
I encourage you to look at.
We have very
sophisticated players
using it in the industry,
and also smaller players.
So this is really something I'd
like you to take away today.
Now we're going to explore a
couple of different campaign
types that can be used and
help you drive installs and app
engagement.
So the first one I'm going
to talk about is video.
So video campaigns are really
good if you want especially
to build up brand awareness,
and also drive installs.
For the most successful
advertisers out there,
we've noticed that usually
videos will trigger users
with higher lifetime value.
Here, we have the
example of Yousician.
So if you want to become
Jimi Hendrix tomorrow,
use Yousician.
You'll learn how to play guitar.
What they did is they used
videos in their ad campaigns.
And they managed to
increase their installs
over 136% as a results.
They launched the campaigns in
over 50 different countries.
A couple of tips to make
sure that your videos can
be very successful--
for app promotion,
you need very short videos.
So that's the first point.
We recommend less
than 20 seconds.
Second tip-- make
sure that you're
showing the brand in the
first second of the video.
Third tip-- you make sure that
you also show the users how
to use the app.
So use a demo.
Very easily use
screenshots from your app
so that the user can
understand actually
what your app is about.
Finally, and last tip
for successful videos,
make sure you have a clear
call to action at the end.
The users need to click
at the end of the video
to be redirected to the store
and then install your app.
With that, I'm going
to move forward
to the second campaign type
I'm going to talk about,
which is search.
So search is enabling you
to drive installs at scale
and will allow
you to reach users
that are going to look
for apps similar to use.
So here, you can see Gett.
Gett is a taxi
service application.
They ran search campaigns both
on the Google Search Network
and the Google Play Store.
And they saw an
increase up to 60%.
I think in Russia, they
saw lower CPIs of 60%.
So this was very
successful for them.
And at the same
time, they managed
to exceed their return
on investment by 150%.
The next campaign type
I'd like to talk about
is once you've decided
to go beyond installs.
So we all know that user
engagement and making sure
that users stay active within
the app is extremely important.
So here the idea is really
to shift from the installs
to actually start
monitoring and optimizing
for in-app events or
in-app activities.
This example is
the one of Happn.
Has anyone used Happn here?
It's a dating app, so all right.
So what they did is they
actually decided to do that.
They wanted to keep
monitoring installs,
but move a bit away further
than the funnel and start
optimizing for registrations.
So they started building
up this Play campaign
to optimize for registration.
And they managed
to decrease by 68%
the cost per registration in
one of their most expensive
segments, which
was women over 25.
So this really
worked well for them.
If I take another
example-- and I'm
thinking about
education apps today--
then optimizing for
registration might be important.
Other things that you
might want to optimize for
is a tutorial
completion, for example,
or is also optimize
for users who
are reaching a certain
number of classing
within your app, or
purchases, ultimately.
Retailers are the same.
They will try to
track different things
and optimize for different
things-- for example, a product
view.
They might also want to
optimize for a search performed
within the app.
They might want to optimize
for an item added to a basket,
and ultimately even go
to the end of the funnel
and optimize for purchase.
Finally, the last piece I'd
like to talk about is engagement
and how to drive successful
engagement campaigns.
So for engagement,
you need to be
very clear with regards to the
strategy you want to adopt.
There could be
several strategies.
If you're a gaming
application, you
might want to go after the
users that have achieved level
5 within your game or above.
Because you know those users are
going to be the most profitable
for you, the ones driving
the most lifetime value.
You could also
very simply decide
to re-engage all the
users who have already
installed your app.
In the case of
Foodpanda, which is
one of our Berlin-based
partners, what they decided
to do through their
engagement display campaigns
is to optimize and go after the
users who had installed the app
or who had already
made a purchase.
And this was
extremely successful--
71% decrease in cost per
install and 37% more sales
when they were comparing the
results of their app campaigns
to their previous run
desktop campaigns.
So it was very, very successful
and paid off a lot for them.
So with that, the recap,
there are a couple
of ways to run paid
acquisitions today and re-engage
your users-- through universal
app campaigns, video campaigns,
search, optimizing beyond the
install for in-app events,
and finally run
re-engagement campaigns.
Thank you, and with that,
I'm handing over to Max.
[APPLAUSE]
MAXIM MAI: Thank you.
Thank you, Marie.
So I hope that there was
something interesting
there for everyone--
some inspiration,
some ideas, or something that
partners or developers here
in the audience are doing.
So I want to remind you,
we're all here today.
So let's chat.
So if you found anything
or heard anything
that was interesting, I'm
sure that Sebastian is very
interested in chatting to you.
Listen to his-- or if
you're interested in PR,
he's an expert in it.
So think about what
was useful there.
And think of how you can
apply it to your project,
to your app.
Now I want to recognize the fact
that growth strategy doesn't
happen in a vacuum.
So it's very, very,
very important
to have a great team and
a culture to support that.
So we were talking
to some of what
we thought were very
successful developers
and experts in the area.
So think of that.
Of the 76 million total
installs that Runtastic
has generated on Play, 95%
were generated organically.
I think that is a
phenomenal number.
And the head of growth
at Runtastic, Mario,
is very, very proud of that KPI.
Because it's a
very good indicator
that they're doing something
right with their growth team
and with their growth strategy.
So the first lesson,
when I talked to him,
that he had for me was, if
you want to do growth right,
it can't be a strategy so much.
It has to be at the
core of the culture.
And it has to inform
everything you do.
So what does he mean by that?
Well, it means that
their growth culture
is codified in a set of
principles at Runtastic.
So one of the
principles, for example,
is, growth is never done.
Or another principle is,
math and metrics don't lie.
But they don't tell everything.
So growth culture
is encapsulated
in these principles.
And these principles then
inform all the processes
that people at Runtastic--
how people at Runtastic work.
It informs how the
teams are staffed
and what tactics
those teams employ.
So he shared with me
this very high-level view
of how their product managers,
designers, and engineers work
together to create their app.
And I think it encapsulates
well the principles at work.
So it applies data.
But it doesn't rely
on data entirely.
The feedback is
also qualitative.
And it also means that
growth is never done.
So you have these
continuous feedback loops
of how they do development.
Another key thing I think that
you need to remind yourself
is that growth strategy
is very cross-functional.
It's a cross-functional
endeavor.
And so the quality
of your execution
will depend on assembling
the right skill
set and the right people in your
team to actually execute well.
So I hope that,
as I said before,
you chat to other developers
here and really try
to get to the bottom of how
other people in the industry
are set up to drive growth.
One last thing I
want to emphasize
is the importance of
continuously tracking
your progress, whether
you use a growth
scorecard or some other device.
It's important with
successful growth strategy
to flag problems
early on so that you
know whether the
investments you're making
are bringing you closer
to the goals you've
stated for your KPIs.
And also, re-evaluate your
growth strategy continuously
as internal and
external factors change.
So that was the first
part of this presentation.
Before I call on Andy,
I just want to give you
a very quick summary.
So first we looked at how
complex the whole topic
of growth is.
But then we luckily introduced
a very simple tool, the growth
framework, to deal with this.
And the first step is to look
at your high-level business
objectives to define
what growth means
for you and for your business.
And then, really focus
only on the techniques
that makes sense for you--
the tactics and the tools
that make sense for you.
And importantly, be
able to track the impact
that you're having.
Also, define really
good KPIs for you
that are measurable
and actionable.
And have some sort of way
of making sure you visualize
whether you're on track.
And then, continuously look
at the data as it comes in.
And track your progress to
make sure you're on track.
And make changes as necessary.
Now Marie and I-- we
covered the framework.
We gave you some examples.
I am thrilled to
hand over to Andy,
who until recently was a
product manager at SoundCloud.
And he is currently
a growth hacker.
Please, I hope he'll share with
you some interesting insights
of how SoundCloud lives
and breathes growth.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDY CARVELL: Thanks.
It's a pleasure to be here.
It's a beautiful day.
So thanks for being in here and
not outside in the sunshine.
Yeah, so as Max said, I actually
just finished at SoundCloud
literally on first of September.
I'm now working with
another ex-SoundClouder.
We set up a mobile
growth consultancy.
So we're helping companies with
exactly this kind of stuff,
like applying the Mobile
Growth Stack framework,
and also writing about growth
topics at mobilegrowthstack.com
But I spent the
last 4 and 1/2 years
at SoundCloud working
on mobile growth.
And the last year
and a half of that
was leading a
cross-functional team
focused on user
retention, which I'm
going to talk about a little
bit today and tell you
why I think it's the most
important growth metric.
And I'll just give you
a little bit of insight
into some of the things that we
did at SoundCloud to increase
retention.
So retention-- it's
really scary when you look
at this graph on the right.
This is a graph that
I often refer to.
It was published by Andrew
Chen in one of his blog posts.
And it shows the average
retention of Android apps
in the Play Store.
And it shows the blue
line there at the top.
That's apps in the top 10.
And what you see on
this curve is that even
a top 10 app loses 50% of its
users in the first 90 days.
And if the app is
not in the top 10,
it's likely to be retaining
users significantly poorer
than that.
It's a really tough
game to retain users.
Because the switching cost for
a user to switch to another app
or just to discard your
app is basically zero.
So it's a constant challenge
to keep your users engaged
and retained.
And of course, if you're
spending money on marketing,
it's really scary to
think that actually you're
paying to acquire users
who are probably not going
to stick around.
So anything you can do
to improve retention
gives you compound growth
over the long term.
And it's going to also be a
multiplier on your acquisition
efforts.
So at SoundCloud, the way
that we looked at retention
was-- I mean, you can
think about retention
in terms of when you look at
your users in any given period.
So for example,
here's an example
from the May users
at SoundCloud.
They broke into these
three different buckets.
So you can think
about you always
have some new users
who just arrived.
And then at SoundCloud
we talked about repeat
and returning users.
So I'm going to
just take a moment
to explain the difference
between those two buckets.
So a repeat user is somebody
who was here in the last period.
And he's here again this
period, or she is here again
this period.
So this is a loyal user
who is currently engaged
and is using your app regularly.
What you often find
is that there's also
a large bucket of what we
refer to as returning users.
So these are users who were
not seen in the last period.
So they were not
seen last month.
But they're here this month.
But they signed up more
than one month ago.
And this bucket actually
is usually pretty large,
particularly if your app's
been around for a while.
And these users
haven't necessarily
churned, in the sense
that they've really
abandoned your app.
They might just be
very casual users.
Maybe they use your app
once or twice a month,
or a few times a year.
And depending on your app and
the particular kind of use case
that you're solving,
maybe that's OK.
But probably most
apps, you really
want users coming back every
week or even every day,
or even multiple times per day.
So really the way that we
approached it at SoundCloud
was that we wanted
people listening
to music on SoundCloud every
day, preferably for many hours.
And so really it was all
about growing that repeat user
bucket-- turning new
users into repeat users
and then keeping them
there, and then reactivating
users who had lapsed.
But reactivation
is really tough.
And I'll talk a bit
more about that later.
So how do we approach this
idea of keeping users engaged,
keeping users from
dropping out of this loop?
And the way that I sort
of conceptualize it
is that you're building
growth machines.
You want to build
repeatable loops, processes,
which through
testing you've proven
to have a strong impact--
or a positive impact
at least-- on your
retention numbers.
So this could be-- I'll talk
about activity notifications
as a prime example
of this in a minute.
But there are other
things you can do.
It could be a loyalty scheme
with points or gamification,
something like
this, anything you
can do that basically you can
put it on sort of autopilot.
Once you've tested it and
optimized it and iterated
on it to a certain level,
it just keeps going.
And it keeps pushing some users
into a higher engaged state.
And it's basically
interacting with users
ideally before they churn.
And so I'll talk a little bit
about activity notifications,
which was actually
one of the projects
that I spent most
of the last year
really building
up at SoundCloud.
It was to build up a new
activity notification
infrastructure for the company.
So what are activity
notifications?
They're real-time
notifications--
could be push, which was
actually the first channel
that we deployed them to.
But it can also be over email.
Could be SMS.
The channel is less
important, I guess,
than the concept,
which is that you're
getting in touch with the
user to tell them something
hopefully interesting
and relevant to them
in a timely fashion about
something that's happened when
they're not in the app.
Now, this is not
always applicable
to every app scenario.
But at SoundCloud,
for example, there
are plenty of things that happen
when you're not in the app
that you might be interested in.
It could be that artists
that you're following
have released new tracks.
And you might want to
be told about them.
Because you might want to
come and listen to them.
It could be that I've
created a playlist,
and somebody has
interacted with it.
Somebody has liked it or
reposted it somewhere.
And so these kind of social
interactions, social signals--
or just new content.
New content is a great one.
And it definitely was
the highest performer
for SoundCloud in terms of
being able to tell people
that, hey, there's new
music that you might
want to come and listen to.
That was fantastic in
terms of performance.
So just to give you some idea,
with the new notifications
that we rolled out, we built
out five new notification types.
And between that
combination, we were
able to increase
retention by around 5%--
absolute percentage points,
which is pretty significant.
So what did we actually build?
It's more than just
coding these notifications
to say, OK, tell the user
that something happened.
What we actually
wanted to build was
a measurement and experimental
framework around that such
that we're actually
able to test and iterate
on these notifications,
and to measure the impact.
Measurement is really a
tough thing with retention.
Because everything
affects retention.
Any product change
that you make is
likely to affect your retention.
Your acquisition mix will
also affect your attention.
So it's really important when
you're running any initiative
that you hope to improve
retention that you always
have some kind of
control group that
is not exposed to
whatever change
that you're going to make.
And that control
group is basically
representing
everything else that's
going on in the platform.
Because it's quite a
volatile number typically.
So we always had a
group of users who never
received any notifications.
And then we would test our new
notifications with test groups
and A/B test all the while
with copy, with timing,
with the different kind
of mix and combination
of notifications
that we would send.
So there's a lot of
experiments to run.
And just as Max was
saying, it's something
that's never really done.
It's never really finished.
So yeah, SoundCloud
will continue
to iterate on these
notifications,
to build out new types.
And I think the next
phase, now that we
have a pretty cool
notification system,
is that they'll start to
add a layer of intelligence
on top of that,
so getting smarter
about optimizing for
relevance of notifications,
which is super important.
And so sort of final
points just on how
to build good
notifications-- it's
really all about
personalization.
And again, this
kind of comes back
to the point about iteration.
So we have a
reactivation notification
that we send to users
when we haven't seen them
in the app for five
days at SoundCloud.
Because we figured out--
again, through testing--
that five days was a good
time to interact with the user
before they're really
likely to churn completely.
But they're already sort of at
risk of churn at that point.
So we'd send them
a notification.
And probably like
a lot of people
who start off with
re-activation,
we started with
something very basic.
It was like, hey, come back and
find more music on SoundCloud--
basically just a very generic,
we miss you, kind of message.
Yeah, perhaps unsurprisingly,
the click rate was super poor.
The impact was
still worth having.
But it was pretty minimal.
And so we thought, OK, how
can we iterate on that?
So what we ended up with,
which is performing way better,
was kind of a three-tiered
approach, where we look at, OK,
has this user shown some kind
of engagement within the app
that we can use in our
re-activation message?
So we looked at, has
a user liked a track?
Because that's a really
high level of engagement,
if they've actually
hit the Like button.
And so if a user liked
a track in the past,
we look at the last
track that they liked.
And in that
re-activation message,
we say, hey-- not just come
back and find some more music
on SoundCloud.
But we say, hey, come back
and find some more music
from Artist X-- Artist X
being the creator of the track
that they liked.
And if they haven't
liked a track,
then we look at the last
track that they played.
And we use that as a signal.
And we personalize
it in the same way.
So if I listened to a Britney
Spears track as my last track,
then we'd say, hey, come
back and find more music
from Britney Spears.
And we found that by using what
you know about the user's usage
history in those messages, you
can really increase the click
rate dramatically.
I think it was something like a
5x increase in our click rate,
albeit from a very low base.
Yeah, time of day can
also be pretty important.
It's probably a good idea not
to be sending push notifications
to people in the
middle of the night.
Of course, if it's a
real-time notification,
if it's important
enough, maybe some people
want to be woken up.
But yeah, again, it's
something to test.
And yeah, really
importantly-- also
to give users granular
control over notifications.
If they can just opt in or out
of notifications in general,
that's going to really
limit your boldness
when you're testing new things.
Because you'll be worried
about people opting out
of push notifications
altogether,
which is a valid concern.
If you give users
the option to opt out
of every individual
class of notifications--
so in other words, say I want
to be told about new tracks.
But I don't care if
people are following me.
I don't want to be
notified about that.
By giving people that
granular level of control,
you can be more experimental
and try bigger ideas.
Because it's likely that
they'll just opt out
of that particular
type of notification
rather than all of
your notifications.
So you can minimize and mitigate
against negative impact.
Yeah, that's it.
That's my short lessons
learned on building an activity
notification system.
And thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]